[موسيقى]
اختتمت الدوره الثانيه من فعاليات مهرجان
البحر الاحمر السينمائي الدولي هذه السنه
شفنا الرضا الكبير عن هذه الدوره وشوفنا
كيف كان النقاد والنجوم من حول العالم
يشوفوها بانها كانت الدوره اجمل وامضج
واكثر تنوعا هذه الدوره حملت الكثير من
المفاجات واستضافه الكثير من النجوم من كل
انحاء العالم خلينا نتعرف اكثر على رايهم
بهذه الدوره وتجربتهم في المهرجان ايش
رايك في الدوري
مفاجاه كبيره من شخص بقى له سبع سنين ما
جاش السعوديه
قبل كده احنا عندنا الجمهوريه الجديده في
دلوقت المملكه العربيه السعوديه الجديده
لهلا اللي شفته وحبيت اذا ما بدك الطاوله
على الايجابيه الموجوده بين الناس والفرح
الموجود على الارض اللي هن فعلا شعبا
والمنظمين بيستهلوه
بالمهرجان واللقاب الاصدقاء والزملاء من
فتره من العام الماضي زي ما قلت انا اهني
المنظمين وكل العاملين في مهرجان البحر
الاحمر و مزيدا من التفوق من الاختيارات
والافلام اللي شفتها انا في القائمه اعتقد
ان التنظيم كان افضل اختيار الافلام كان
مميز كذلك انا ابارك للفائزين هذه الليله
عن الفوز سواء كان مخرجين او افلام خاصه
السعوديه وكذلك بالنسبه للافلام الدوليه
والعربيه
من عمل هيك هسه وهو من الوطن العربي
بالسعوديه بيلبق لهم شعب هيك
بيلبق له يستضيف عالم
كنت بالرياض امبارح واليوم بجده
مبسوطه كثير هيك بالتفاعل تبع العالم
وفراود لوين وصلنا نحن اليوم بالسنه معه
انا متحمسه ومبهوره صراحه كل سنه يصير
احلى هالسنه يعني طبعا غير واكبر وكل سنه
لا لا مميزاتها وصراحه يعني
حابه فيها التنوع النجوم تنوع الدورات
وتنوع النقاشات وكمان تنوع الافلام اللي
فيها سواء كانت عالميه او سعوديه انا
شايفها عندك من الدوره الاولى احلى همم
اغلى اقوى فيها افلام احلى فيها نجوم قطار
اكثر على يمين وعرب ومصريين همم سعيد
بالدوره جدا حقيقي
ومبسوطه قوي ان السعوديه وصلت للمرحله
المتطوره دي في وقت قليل جدا
السعوديه اهل السعوديه اهل الكرم واهل خير
همم
بيكرموا الضيف بزياده بصراحه مبسوطه حسنا
انا في وسط اهلي الشايب اللي شفته
بالمكالمه
[موسيقى]
اليوم عشان الدوره
يمكن احلى كمان
وهذا الشيء هيخلي الافلام تتوزع بشكل افضل
وتسافر بشكل الافطار
[موسيقى]